[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
India is the world's largest democracy
with more than 1.3 billion inhabitants
we are talking about an ally of the
United States an increasingly important
Ally too and perhaps that is why during
the Shanghai cooperation organization
Forum Indian Prime Minister Narendra
Modi reproached Putin for his
intervention in Ukraine
Indian PM Modi tells Russia's Putin now
is not an era for war
at the same time however on a day-to-day
basis India has not joined the sanctions
against Russia and what's more take a
note of this hindu's Russian oil imports
jump over 50 times since April you heard
correctly as soon as the Russian
invasion of Ukraine began India started
buying Russian oil like there was no
tomorrow and we're not talking about a
slight increase almost 50 times more
dinosaur juice than they were importing
before obviously India is not the only
country that has ignored economic
sanctions remember that oil is the basis
of the Russian economy if all countries
stop buying oil from Russia they would
struggle to be able to continue the war
in Ukraine in other words the fact that
India has bought so much oil from Russia
virtually overnight could be a real
Lifeline for Moscow or maybe not but do
you know what is the most curious thing
of all but despite all this India
continues to strengthen its ties with
the United States you don't believe me
or pay attention to this
U.S seeking increased arms sales with
India amid Russian sanctions I know your
heads have exploded haven't they
to give you an idea
Korean War started Joe Baden has met
twice with his Indian counterpart
Narendra Modi and in both cases Biden
has said the same thing oh Narendra Modi
buying oil from Russia is so bad do you
think it's nice don't you see what Putin
is doing in Ukraine I think it's so
wrong but go ahead here's 500 million
dollars so you can buy guns but you
don't deserve it literally the United
States is preparing a 500 million dollar
military aid package for India U.S seeks
to wean India from Russia weapons with
arms Aid package potential 500 million
dollar deal would put India near Israel
Egypt India is the largest buyer of
russian-made military hardware and all
this despite the fact that India is
ignoring the sanctions against Russia
and the question is why is India
supporting Russia in this war could
India really save the Russian economy
from Western sanctions and more
importantly why despite all this does
the U.S continue to collaborate with
India on such important things as
defense today we're going to answer all
of these questions but first let's look
at some history
foreign
Between Two Worlds
since 1955 India has belonged to the
third world literally the term third
world came into use at the bang dung
conference in 1955. at this conference
all the countries that did not want to
take sight in the cold war came together
if the capitalist block was the first
world the Communist Bloc the second
world they would be the third world on
this list were countries like Indonesia
Yugoslavia and India think about it
after Independence India had a hybrid
system between two Big Blocks
politically India is a liberal democracy
like any other Western Country however
from an economic point of view India is
as far from capitalism in many cases
they have even had five-year plans in
other words it was a country faced to be
on good terms with the two blocks
[Music]
foreign
unlike the West the Soviet Union was
always on India's side for key issues
for India for example in all U.N votes
they have always supported India and its
conflict with Pakistan over Kashmir in
this respect the United States has a
much more ambivalent possession and what
about India's nuclear program in 1974
India made the first test of its nuclear
bomb the United States responded with an
economic sanctions Russia however began
supplying India with heavy water and
nuclear advice
[Music]
it's not just about diplomacy we're also
talking about weapons and believe me
this is the fundamental pillar of
indo-russian relationships
[Music]
to give you an idea as of 2016 69 of
India's arms Imports came from Russia
naturally as a good non-aligned country
New Delhi has also purchased arms from
other countries instituting the United
States however its main supplier by far
is Russia and why you may ask well the
main reason is because they're cheaper
plain and simple Russian Weaponry may
have many flaws but as far as price is
concerned it is super competitive and as
you can imagine we are not only talking
about weapons but also about the parts
to repair them 80 of the India's Arsenal
spare parts come from Russia and the
list goes on
[Music]
you can also talk about the energy
sector yes it is true India hardly uses
gas in its energy mix only six percent
of India's electricity comes from gas
however in 2019 the Indian government
and the Russian state-owned company
rostacom reached an agreement of an
intent to build at least six new nuclear
reactors at the moment the Russian
company is building the fifth and sixth
reactors at the kunda Kalam power plant
one of the country's main power plants
[Music]
in other words relations between India
and Russia have always been very close
in fact six out of the ten Indians
support their government maintaining
ties with Moscow despite the war now are
we talking about committed support or
simply economic interest well let's take
a look at that right now
[Music]
one step East two steps West
[Music]
in 2014 Narendra Modi became the prime
minister of India but who is Narendra
Modi what is his ideology you could say
that Modi is a populist leader very
Nationalist and absolutely popular among
his citizens to give you an idea his
party holds more than 60 of the seats in
the lower house and what ideology does
this man profess well to summarize we
could say that modi's program is based
on three pillars on the one hand we have
Ultra nationalism next to Narendra Modi
Donald Trump would look like a tree
hugging hippie the second pillar of his
government is technocracy Modi came to
power with the promise of ending India's
hyper bureaucratization well let's just
say the results are debatable however
the third pillar of the Modi government
is none other than closer ties with the
west and believe me in this regard
Narendra modi's diplomacy has been quite
enlightened
[Music]
despite being more trumpets than Trump
himself Modi was a personal friend of
Barack Obama's what's more Obama went so
far as to write a profile for Time
Magazine where he seemed to declare
undying love for the man not
surprisingly during the Trump
Administration New Delhi and Washington
got along flawlessly and you will see
beyond the words what does it mean to
get along closer to the West well among
other things it means making all kinds
of security alliances it's very simple
to defend itself against one of India's
greatest adversaries and who am I
talking about Pakistan no another much
more powerful country and a much more
fearsome one too China that explains for
instance why India is part of the Quad a
strategic Alliance that includes the
United States Australia Japan and India
but once again we're not just talking
about diplomacy we're also talking about
facts more specifically Weaponry
[Applause]
let's be clear Russian weapons are cheap
because they mess more than amusement
park shotgun if you have any doubts take
a look at Ukraine or watch the
visualpolitik video dedicated to the
Russian military industrial complex and
as you can imagine with such a flawed
Arsenal it is difficult to deter an
increasingly powerful China India needs
to be able to call on Western weaponry
and believe me in this regard Modi is
not wasting any time take a look at this
chart
[Music]
an idea prior to 2016 almost 70 of arms
Imports came from Russia now they are
less than 30 percent France is already
selling them Raphael and Mirage fighter
jets
and I know what you're all thinking
didn't we say that U.S weapons are very
expensive yes they are they are very
expensive and India doesn't have that
kind of money so what's the solution
here
the solution consists for example of
creating joint ventures with Indian
companies that is an American
manufacturer signs an agreement with an
Indian manufacturer to work together to
produce an aircraft with many cost
savings and while perhaps more limited
than the US versions much more effective
in any case than the Russian ones
so what is the problem with this type of
agreement the problem is that India is
still a highly centralized country the
arms industry is dominated by
hyper-bureaucratized state-owned
Industries companies such as Hindustan
Aeronautics limited and that explains
why in 2020 Modi opened the door to
foreign investment which can now have up
to 74 ownership and an Arms Company and
believe me this measure is already
starting to take effect check this out
Lockheed Martin and Tata Advanced
systems signed a landmark agreement
affirming the companies intend to join
hands to produce the F-16 block 70 in
India however changing your entire
Arsenal is something that cannot be done
overnight
[Music]
Russia remains crucial to India in both
defense and energy and that is why Modi
has decided not to sanction Russia is
that a good idea is it a bad idea we on
visualpolitik certainly can applaud him
but one thing is certain India is
gleaning a lot out of this situation
India attempts to diversify energy
sources with cheap Russian oil to give
you an idea before the war Russia
accounted only for 0.5 of India's oil
supply now it is more than 10 in April
2021 India bought around 22 500 barrels
of Russian oil per day in April 2022 the
figure was over 680 000 and the sharpest
of you will already be saying aha you
see this is how Russia can grow despite
the sanctions right instead of selling
oil to the Europeans now it says oil to
the Indians with a much larger
population right well no in reality it
is new daily that has really scored the
deal here
as the United States and Europe have
stopped buying dinosaur juice from
Russia the price is inflated to
astronomic levels at some points the
price of a barrel of Brent has reached
over 120 however no wealthy country
wants to buy oil from Russia and that is
when India arrives and says my friend my
comrade my tovarek don't worry I am here
to buy oil from you but since I am
practically the only buyer you will let
me have a friendly price wouldn't you
how about a discount of I don't know say
thirty dollars per barrel and Russia has
no choice but to jump through the Hoops
in other words India has been buying oil
well below the market price put another
way in this business there is little
ideology or friendship and a lot of
taking advantage of the situation Europe
was importing more than 3.1 million
Russian barrels a day this was before
the war India is buying around 680 000
barrels a day in other words should
Europe stop buying oil from Russia
completely which is quite likely India
will not be able to compensate for the
losses neither in price nor in quantity
so now the question is why does Biden
continue to tighten cooperation with
India we're going to look at that now
[Music]
the string of pearls
Beyond Russia the biggest threat to
Western Security is China and in this
regard India's interest could not be
more aligned with the West in this
respect India has a lot to lose just
remember that China and India have had
border disputes of All Sorts every few
years there is some Skirmish on the
Himalayan border but without a doubt the
worst threat is
check out this map
what you are seeing here is the string
of perils strategy that is a series of
ports funded by China and strategically
placed to encircle India if necessary we
are talking about ports in Pakistan Sri
Lanka and Bangladesh in theory these
ports are intended for civilian use but
they are paid for by China and Pakistan
Sri Lanka and Bangladesh are very weak
economies so at any given moment China
could pressure them to allow the Chinese
Navy to operate from them
for years China has been exercising what
we on pure visual politics call Sugar
Daddy diplomacy we have explained it
several times in previous videos in
short China can convert these ports to
military use very easily and that's
quite a threat to India's security that
explains all of new delhi's diplomatic
and military alliances with Washington
so what could India bring to the table
to deter China you may ask a lot one
thing in particular geography take a
look at this other map
[Music]
[Applause]
what you see here is the Strait of
Malacca one of the epicenters of global
trade more than 70 of the gas and oil
that reaches China passes through here
it would only take cutting the transit
of ships for one day for the Chinese
economy to collapse from one moment to
the next and which countries could cut
this traffic exactly India and how could
they do it well very simply see these
other Islands here these are the Andaman
and nicobar Islands a virtually
uninhabited archipelago until a few
years ago these islands were known only
to the indigenous tribes that inhabited
them now however things are changing a
lot around there check this out new
naval base in andaman's boost military
Terry posture in Indian Ocean all of
this explains why the United States is
so interested in improving ties with
India in this respect what India is
doing with Russia is on the back burner
Washington's interest is that New Delhi
has a decent military ready to deter
China everything else is secondary
besides to what extent is it so crucial
for India to buy oil from Russia
think about it at the time of making
this video the debate with India is
about the price cap on Russian oil many
G7 countries that is the world's largest
economies want to set a maximum price
for oil coming from Russia for that to
work all the major economies would have
to agree and it seems that India is not
willing to join in at least not at the
time of making this video the question
then is does it really make a big
difference think about it if India is
buying Royal from Russia it's because
they're already selling to them well
below the market price in other words
cap or no cap on spending India is only
interested in Siberian dinosaur juice if
they can get it for a bargain price
conclusion for the moment it does not
seem that Washington is very concerned
about India doing business out of the
Ukrainian War the important thing in
this case is India's position on China
and at this point the questions are over
to you do you think India will ever
revamp his entire Arsenal with Western
Weaponry would it be a good idea to put
pressure on India to join the sanctions
against Russia you can leave us your
answer in the comments below and as
always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to our Channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know all the best and I'll see you
next time
foreign